Tattersall: Well, hey, everyone,
and a very warm welcome
to the last session
of Google I/O 2011.
I'm really, really
touched to see
so many of you come here today.
So today, we're talking
about Google Tasks.
My name is David,
and I am the product manager
for Google Tasks.
We've come all the way
from the Zurich office
in Switzerland
to talk to you today.
If you are tweeting along
on your laptops
or your new tablets,
you can use the hashtags
#io2011 or #googleapps,
and also while you're on there,
you also might want
to follow is on @googletasks.
During the session, there
will be a SpeakerMeter link
so you can submit live feedback
as we're going along,
and you can find that at
the Google short link there.
Whoops.
So... so...
towards the end of last year,
we decided to help
put a survey up
and ask our users what they
thought we should focus on,
uh, over the coming year.
After all, Google's--
Google's motto is basically
focus on the user,
and all else will follow,
and we were
absolutely overwhelmed
by the response
we got through this.
We canvassed the best part
of 200,000 votes
from just under 20,000 people,
and we noticed two really,
really main things
that stuck out from this.
The first thing is
people asked us,
Can we have
our tasks everywhere?
We can already access
our tasks in Google Mail
or in Google Calendar,
and even on an iGoogle gadget
on my homepage,
but I want to access it
from my mobile device.
I want to be able
to access Tasks
from many third-party web apps
which I use every day.
And the second thing
which people asked us for,
to make all this possible--
somebody said to us,
"An API for third-party apps
would be absolutely incredible."
Somebody else said to us, "Tasks
needs an API so badly it hurts."
So we--we saw this
and we thought about it,
and we, uh, we agreed with you.
So this morning,
we're happy to announce
the launch of the very first
Google Tasks API.
[applause]
Tattersall: So it's with
the release of this API
that we're really
looking to you guys
to help provide this universal
access to Tasks,
which our users have been
asking for so badly.
So we all know that you've
really come to this conference
to see demos on Android phones,
so we're gonna try
our first one straightaway.
So here, you can see this is my,
uh, this is my GMAIL account,
and I've set up
a little task list
of things we want to talk about
during the day.
Can we have the projector on?
So on your--you'll have
to bear with us.
We are tempting
the Wi-Fi gods a bit,
trying a demo
with a live device.
This is all completely live.
So what you can see here
is my Android phone
is showing you my task lists,
and these are fetched directly
from Google's service.
This is all using the Java
client libraries that we provide
out of the box.
It all works fine with Android.
So I can click into "Shopping
Lists" and you can see a bunch
of stuff that we need to buy
for our launch party tonight.
So Andreas has got
the frozen pizza,
but we still need
a few other things.
I'm gonna click
into the Google I/O list,
and you can see the things
that I want to talk about today.
So let's try
and check off "Introduction."
So now the phone
is communicating
back through the API--
fingers crossed--
to the Google service,
and if we can switch back here--
if, I, uh...
We can see they got checked off,
so that is the first live demo
of the Google Tasks API working.
So this--that's basically--
The rest of the session
is gonna be about
how you can build applications
just like this,
which synchronize and engage
with Google Tasks.
So that's my introduction
over with.
Fabian's now gonna come up
and talk a bit about
the data structure
and how we represent things
like task lists and tasks
and some of the kind of nuances
around that.
Andreas is actually
gonna show you issues
from live call to the API and do
a live demo to run you through
a few common actions you might
be interested in, to show you
actually what you need to do
to get the data back you want,
and then Nicolas
is gonna come up
and a little bit high-level
about the languages we support,
the client libraries, how to use
them, and also, since we think
a lot of you will be really
interested in synchronization,
he's gonna walk through
a sample sync logic for you.
And we've also had several teams
using the API
over the past month or so,
so I'm gonna invite Mavenlink,
Zoho, and Producteev
to share what they've done,
to give you some cool demos,
and also talk a bit
about what they learned
and, um, some light lessons
and stuff like that.
So I'd like
to invite up Fabian--
Oh, before I invite up Fabian,
if you need to, uh,
if you're online, you can go
straight to this URL.
You can see all the
documentation, client libraries,
and we might have enough
for a prize if someone manages
to get a working integration
by the end of the session,
so, Fabian.
Schlup: Thanks, David.
Schlup: Hi, everyone.
I'm Fabian, and...
[speaking indistinctly]
Google Tasks team in Zurich.
Can you hear me? Yes.
As you've just seen
with David's demonstration,
the Tasks API allows you
for the first time
to access the tasks
as we see them today
in GMAIL and in Calendar,
and the iGoogle gadget,
for example.
Um, so I'm gonna, you know,
walk with you through the basics
of the Tasks API now.
Who of you has attended
the "Life of a Google
API Developer" talk yesterday?
Schlup: Very few? Okay.
[laughs]
So if you would have
attended that talk,
you would find that much of what
has been covered there,
you can apply to the Tasks API,
as we have, you know,
built that API
on Google's new
API infrastructure.
but actually, I'm glad
many of you haven't attended,
because then you're gonna
learn more here.
So let's get started
with a brief overview.
The Tasks API is available
at googleapis.com,
and as many APIs
at Google nowadays,
it's based on secure HTTP,
on the RESTful
architectural style,
and on JSON
for data representation.
It's integrated
with the API Console,
which some of you might already
be familiar with.
It's a dashboard that allows
you as a developer
to configure and register
your project
and gives you access to
traffic reports, for example,
where you can see
how many requests
your application sends
to the Tasks API.
This can be particularly useful
if you're writing a client
application, for example,
that you distribute to users
and that talks
to the Tasks API directly.
And this way, you usually don't
really have a good handle
on how many requests
you send to us,
and so this is
a great way to see.
Also, you can regis--
or you can configure
per-user traffic limits
and stuff like that.
Schlup: The API is available
in the API's Explorer, as well.
It's a Web interface to many
of Google's--Google's APIs,
and it makes it really easy
to explore and discover an API
through a Web browser.
You can discover the methods
and the operations
that are available.
You can even send requests
and receive responses
and see how it all works
without having to write
a single line of code
or dealing with authentication
and so on,
and Andreas is gonna show you
a demo of the Tasks API
using the Explorer
in just a minute.
We also provide a set
of client libraries
for major programming languages.
That will help you to get
something up and running
rather quickly.
But so let's dive into
the specifics
of Google Tasks and the new API.
When we look at the task lists,
at our I/O task list here,
in--as it looks in GMAIL,
on the left-hand side,
we can see a bunch of tasks.
One has already been completed,
some are nested,
and on the right-hand side,
we can see the details
for a particular task.
We see stuff like due date,
additional notes
that I can put in there.
So there's basically
two entities to the system,
which is tasks and task lists,
and that's exactly
the two types of resources
that we expose
through the RESTful API.
Schlup: A list really just
only has a title.
There's not much else to it.
A task has several more fields
that hold all the information
that we've just seen--
title, due date, notes,
and so on,
not all of which
are listed here.
To that, I want
to point out quickly,
because they don't correspond
that directly
to something that we experience
in the UI,
is the parent field
and the position fields
that we have in our resource.
For a nested task,
the parent field will indicate
the I.D. of the parent task
under which this one is nested,
and the position field
is a string
that lets us find out
about the ordering
that the user defined in the UI.
But I'll--I'll go into that
in a minute.
So to get started
and find out about
what lists a user has,
we provide a collection
at a fixed URL
ending in /users/@me/lists,
which will contain
or which contains all the lists
of the authenticated user.
So that's a great entry point
for an application
to find out about, you know,
the lists that a user has
if you've never
dealt with that user before.
And then similarly, for--
for, like, to find out about
the tasks on a specific list,
there is a collection that will
hold that information,
and the URL contains the I.D.
of the list that you're actually
interested in.
So we basically have
two types of resources,
two types of collections,
that we can interact with
in a RESTful way.
Who of you is familiar
with the RESTful style
of--of talking to APIs?
Great. Many of you are,
so I'm just gonna run through
the basic operations,
uh, so we're on the same page.
I listed the full URL end point
of the two collections
in the system at the top,
and the operations
that we can do on a collection
is we can insert new element
or we can just read back
the full list
as a JSON ob--
in a JSON representation,
basically,
using HTTP POST or GET.
And then the resources,
so the individual
tasks and lists
within these collections--
their URL looks very similar
to the one of the collection.
They just contain their specific
I.D.'s appended to the end,
like this,
and on individual resources,
we have three operations
that we can basically perform,
which is update that resource
by sending a new representation,
delete it,
or read back
that specific resource,
again, by using HTTP GET,
PUT, or DELETE.
In the Tasks API,
there's also something
that looks
a little bit different
that's related to ordering,
and I just mentioned
the position field before.
Here, I put a bunch of tasks
and I put,
on the right-hand side,
what the value of these
position fields could be
for each one of these tasks.
Remember, it's a string,
so it's not just numbers,
but I put it here to make it
a bit more simple.
The position string lets us know
what the--or how the user
ordered his task in the UI,
and so by ordering the tasks
by that string,
lexicographically,
we will end up
with the right, um, order
as the user defined it
in the UI.
And as you--
as tasks can be nested,
this position string
always just applies
to the tasks on the same level,
just among the sibling tasks
under the same parent.
They will define that ordering.
So how about if we want
to move a task
from, say, the end
to, you know, under task 1 here
and in between the two children
that are already there?
In the UI, I can do this
with a simple drag and drop
and it's done.
In the API, we wanted
to do something similar
and make it as easy as possible,
so we provide a "move" method.
It's basically, you take the URL
of a specific task,
you append/move,
and then you specify the I.D.
of both the new parent task
that you want
to move your task under,
and the I.D. of the task
that you want to move your task
immediately after of,
so the new previous task
in the ordering.
And what the API
will do for you, then,
is to move the task
exactly there,
which is conceptually
updating its parent field
to the new parent,
1 in this case,
and updating its position string
to an appropriate value
so that the ordering will again,
you know, result in the--
if you order
by that string again,
it will result
in the right order.
But let's do
some hands-on example,
and I'm gonna
leave the stage to Andreas,
who's gonna show you
the Tasks API in the Explorer.
[applause]
Signer: Thanks, Fabian,
for that great introduction
on how the Tasks API works.
Um, now it's time to look at
some real examples in the wild.
Um, in the next few minutes,
I'm going to show you
how you can use the Tasks API
to actually modify and manage
the tasks and task lists,
and we're also going to look at
the exact requests
and responses
that you have to send
and that you will get back.
To do so, I'm going to use
the APIs Explorer,
as Fabian already mentioned.
It's really a great tool
for experiments like that,
because it allows you to easily
explore the APIs
Google is exposing,
discover new features--
you'll see some short
documentation--write in it.
You don't have to write
any line of code.
Everything can be done using
the really easy-to-use UI,
um, and it's available at
code.google.com/apis/explorer,
so let me switch to the browser.
This is the main page
of the APIs Explorer.
On the left-hand side,
you can see all the services
that are exposed
by the Explorer.
For this demo, obviously, we are
going to use the Tasks API,
so I select "Tasks."
Next to it,
you'll see the versions.
We just launched,
so there's only v1.
APIs Explorer already
preselected that.
And right next to it,
you'll see all the methods
that are exposed by that API.
Um, this demo will focus on
a sort of simple
but still real-world scenario.
We are going to pick a task
from one of our task lists
and then tick it off.
So the first thing
I want to see is,
What task lists do I have?
To do that,
I browse through
the mess--methods, excuse me.
and there's tasklists.list.
Documentation says it returns
the user's task lists,
but you have
to be authenticated,
so let's quickly switch
to private access.
Now we're using private access.
We selected
the tasklists.list method,
and we can see the parameters
that are supported
by that method.
We have maxResults,
which is optional
and defaults to 100,
so we don't need
to set anything there.
Then there's a pageToken
that would allow you
to do pagination.
If you don't want to get
the whole data set back,
we don't want to set
anything there, as well,
so all we have to do is execute,
and on the bottom of the screen,
you see now the request
and the response.
Let me make this
a little bigger.
Signer: On the first line,
you see the request
that was actually issued
against our servers.
You see that default URL
that points to the collection
containing all my task lists,
and you see the response.
200. That's--that's great.
Everything worked.
And we got back a collection
containing two items.
One is the shopping list that
David showed in the beginning,
and the other thing is
the Google I/O task list.
This is the one where we're
pretty sure that our task is on,
so let me quickly copy
the I.D. of the task list,
because we're going
to need it in a minute.
Now we switch back,
and now let's look at
all the tasks
that are actually
on that task list.
To do that, we pick
the method tasks.lists,
which returns all tasks
in a certain list.
Now there's
the parameter tasklist
that needs to be provided,
and it should contain the I.D.
of the task list
we want to look at,
so let's paste in that I.D.
There are a bunch of
other parameters, as well.
Those allow you to do
a sort of fine-grained query.
You can specify when the task
had to be completed
or when it's due.
Currently, we're not
interested in that.
We just want to see everything
on that list,
so we only populate
the tasklist parameter
and click on Execute again.
Signer: In the request
that was sent,
you can now see that we switched
from the collection
of all my task lists
to the collection of all tasks
on one given list.
The response was, again, okay,
and we see there's four items
in that result set.
I'm currently demoing how you
can use the Tasks API,
so let's just tick off
that task.
Ticking off a task
basically just means
upload the task again
with a different status.
Currently, the status
is "needsAction,"
which means that
it's not ticked yet,
so let's change that status
to "completed."
I'm copying away
the whole data of that task
because this is what
I'm going to modify
and upload,
and updating a task
is done using tasks.update.
It only takes two parameters,
the tasklist I.D.
and the task I.D.,
and, of course, a request body
which contains the data that
we're actually going to send,
so I click on the link.
I paste in the data
that we copied before.
I change the status from
"needsAction" to "completed,"
and I'm pasting in
the task I.D.'s again.
This is the tasklist I.D.,
and somewhere below...
Signer: Here's our task
that we were updating.
Here's the I.D. of that task.
Signer: And we
execute the request.
You can see that API Explorer
now issued a PUT request,
because we're actually
updating data
and are uploading, um--we're
updating a task, excuse me,
and are uploading data.
You see the data
that we uploaded
with the new status "completed."
If we look at the response,
it's again 200.
That's pretty cool,
and the server also--
or the API also returns the data
as it sees it at the moment,
so you see the status
has been changed to "completed,"
and in addition to that,
the server also set
the "completed" time stamp,
which is the time when
the server received the request.
Signer: As you can see,
it's really straightforward
to use the APIs Explorer.
It's great.
You can just try out stuff.
You immediately get responses.
You immediately see
all the errors.
Theoretically, you could now
use those requests
and write your applications,
but luckily, we have a clientlib
that makes it
even more comfortable
to talk to the Tasks API.
and Nicolas is going
to talk about
how to write apps
using those libs.
[applause]
Garnier: All right.
Thanks, Andreas.
So hi, everyone.
My name is Nicolas,
and I am part of the Tasks API
Developer Relations Team.
So as Andreas mentioned,
I'm going to show you how we can
use our client libraries,
and specifically one of them,
through a common
synchronization scenario,
but first, let's see
what kind of libraries
are available today.
So we currently have available
two libraries for
strongly typed languages,
Java and .NET,
and three for dynamic languages,
so Python, PHP, and Ruby.
So what's really interesting
about the three client libraries
for dynamic languages
is that they are actually gonna
use our API Discovery mechanism,
um, to actually know
how to parse
the response from the API,
and how to generate messages
to send to the API
so they're basically generic
for all our APIs that support
the Discovery mechanism,
and they're basically gonna,
you know, automatically,
uh, and dynamically offer you
a business layer,
basically, to use.
So this one library
are basically,
uh, making it easy for you to,
for example, authenticate
using OAuth 1 and 2,
which is definitely not
trivial to implement.
They're also gonna handle,
you know, all the data
from that handling,
such as parsing the response,
and generating the, you know,
JSON outputs
to the API, et cetera.
For example, here, on that side,
you can see that the--
using the Java and the Python
client library,
you can actually get
your default tasks list
really easily with a one-liner,
and then, you know,
parse through those tasks
really easily and in
the language specifically.
Uh, so we're now going to,
uh, to go through a common,
but, you know, a simple but
common synchronization scenario,
and that's basically what we're
doing on our Android app
that David
has shown you earlier.
So there's multiple aspects
to that synchronization.
The first aspect is that
at any moment, of course,
a user can use your app
and modify a task,
so that's gonna modify
the local version of your task,
since you're gonna
keep, basically,
probably a local copy
of all your tasks
in a--in the local database.
So also, at any moment,
a user or any other app
using the API
can modify the task that's--
the remote task that's
located on Google's server,
and therefore, which--
therefore, you're gonna
have to synchronize to.
Um, there's also
the second aspect of that,
is you're gonna run--we're gonna
run a periodic job.
Uh, basically, that can be done,
you know, through a sync adapter
on an Android app
or using a scheduled task story
on an App Engine app,
or, you know, any other type
of periodical job
on your own platform.
So what we're gonna do during
this periodical job
is we're gonna send
all the local modifications
to the API, the one that,
you know, your user
has modified,
and then you're gonna get all
the modifications from the API,
so we're gonna see that
in a minute,
you know, how you can do that
using, uh, using some code.
So to actually do that,
we're gonna use--
and I'd like
to--to show you this, too,
like, really useful API features
that are available
in the Tasks API today,
is the ability to do
conditional modification.
You can do that by setting
an If-Match header
along with your request,
uh, to the etag of the task,
so the etag is like
a version number
that your task is gonna--I mean,
that's assigned to your task.
Um, when you do
a conditional modification,
for example, a conditional
update of your task,
what's gonna happen is that
if the task has been modified,
you know, on Google's
server remotely,
so basically, if the task
is not at the same version,
you have a, you know,
that you got the last time
you synchronized,
uh, the update is gonna fail,
and the API
is gonna let you know
that your task is different,
and that there's a conflict
to handle, basically.
The second feature
is the ability to do polling,
so that's very common
in many of our APIs,
so you can use
the updatedMin URL parameter,
setting a date, and using--
and then the API is basically
gonna return you
all the modifications
that happened since that date.
So first, let me ask you,
Who is not a Java developer
in the room?
Who doesn't know Java?
All right, I'm not
raising my hand,
though it's kind of weird,
because that's my hand
on the screen, you know?
[laughter]
Signer: Thank you. I didn't
expect this joke to work, but...
[laughs] Yeah, you know,
it's really hard to get
a commercially licensed image,
so I just took my hand.
Uh, all right, so I apologize
to you all,
because, um,
yeah, all the samples--
upcoming samples
are gonna be in Java,
so hopefully, that was only
a couple people in the room.
So, uh, what do you
first need to do--
you know, the first action?
A user modify your tasks
on your app, basically.
So, obviously, you're gonna have
to save all the modifications
on your local database.
Then you're gonna mark the entry
as having been modified,
so here, we don't push
the modification straightaway.
We just marked it as
"Needs to be updated later,"
during the sync cycle.
Uh, then, very important,
you need to save the modified
date of the task,
you know, the date as--
when the user basically
modified your task.
That's gonna be useful
when you need to, you know,
handle merging between two tasks
or, you know, conflicts.
I'm not gonna show any code here
because that's--basically
depends, you know,
on your local database
or the platform you're using.
There's no specific
API codes here.
Um, then the second aspect
of the synchronization,
the periodic job,
which is a little
more interesting for us.
The first part of this is you
are gonna push, periodically,
all the modifications that
your user has done to the API.
So here are
all the tasks involved,
so the first part of this
is to get all the tasks
that have been marked
from your local database.
So, again, no specific API code.
I'm just gonna mark, you know,
in bold blue like this,
uh, all the methods that are
up to you to develop,
basically, that use your,
you know, your own database,
or, you know, other things
that's basically up to you.
Then in the green box here,
we're gonna do
the conditional update,
so, you know, updating
a task conditionally--
If the task has changed,
please let us know, basically,
that's what it does.
And then you have to remove
that modified marker,
so it doesn't--you don't keep
updating the task
on the next periodic cycle.
So this is how you can do that
using our Java client library.
So usually, you know,
updating a task is a one-liner,
um, you know,
the second line here,
uh, to which we've added
setting the If-Match header,
so using the etag of the tasks,
and executed,
and, you know, then
you remove the marker,
uh, that the task
needs to be updated.
And then, of course,
we shall not forget
to, um, actually
handle conflicts,
so if a, you know,
a conflict happened,
this, you know, this, uh,
this update, um, failed,
the API is gonna return to you
a 412 Precondition Failed error,
so an HTTP error, 412,
and you can actually catch that
using the HTTP response
exception in Java
and just checking
the status code,
because that's the exception
we're gonna return
every time the API does not
return 200, basically,
or, you know, 2XX.
200, 201, et cetera.
So here, if it's
a 201--212--412, sorry,
there's basically
a conflict to handle,
so basically,
you're gonna have to merge
your local version of your tasks
and the remote one,
since, you know, they differ now
and, um, they've both
been modified
in two different systems.
So a quicker--a quick word
about these merging strategies.
Uh, there's many of them.
Probably the most common one
is just to simply keep
the last modified task--
I mean, version of the task,
of the two.
So you're gonna look
on Google's server,
you know, Oh, when has
this task been modified?
and the one you have,
and just pick the latest one--
I mean, the latest modified one.
There's also a few other ones.
For example, you could choose
your version to always win,
to always take, you know,
be preferred.
You could also just
prompt the user,
you know, ask him,
Oh, there's a conflict.
Do you want to keep your version
or update to this one?
You could also try
to do per-field merge,
in which case,
you would need to keep
a modified date on each field,
and then you could actually do
per-field merge in some cases.
Could be really interesting,
and I'm just gonna show you
how you can do this,
I mean, to keep
the last modified strategy,
you know, merge strategy,
using our library.
So it's also pretty simple.
You're just gonna get
the remote task
that has the same I.D.
and the same list,
and then you're gonna, you know,
compare the two time stamps,
and then just, you know,
choose whether you need to save
the remote task
in your local database,
or just, you know, update again
the remote task,
uh, I mean, on the API,
this time not conditionally,
just erasing it.
You could also still
do it conditionally,
but using the new etag
of the task you just got done.
You know, just to make sure
the task has not been modified,
if you're really unlucky,
between the first
and the fourth line.
All right, then the second part
of the synchronization here
is we're gonna get
all the modified tasks
from the API, and, you know,
update your local database.
So here are some
of the tasks involved.
Uh, we're basically
doing polling,
so we're using
the "updatedMin" parameter.
It's, again,
pretty simple to use.
Usually, getting
the default task list
only--is only a one-liner.
Then we're gonna set
the "updatedMin"
URL parameter, as I said,
to a date to which
you've--you've saved,
so basically, the date
of your last sync.
You also have--
you should not forget,
that's really important--
to ask the API to show you
all the deleted tasks,
basically, all the tasks
that have been deleted.
Basically, it's gonna
return you tombstones,
you know, like,
letting you know,
oh, those five tasks
have been deleted.
That way, you can update
your local database
and the--you know,
remove those tasks.
Then that's not really
API-specific.
You're just gonna save that
to your local database,
you know, erase
and update your tasks.
Um, and yeah, sorry,
the last part here,
in the green box,
is you're gonna have to save
this new date, you know?
Oh, that's my new
synchronization date.
I want to use this date
for, you know, next round.
So instead of just saving
the current date of your system,
in which case you would
need your server,
you know, really in sync
with Google's servers,
a common trick here is just
to, actually, through--
I mean, beyond the task
you've just got on here,
on the previous subpart,
you're just gonna, you know, try
to find the latest updated task,
and just keep that date,
and reuse that date
for, you know, next update.
That way, you don't really
rely on having,
you know, your two clocks
synchronized with Google.
That's a, you know,
common--common code.
Then you're gonna save that date
and, you know use that
for later.
So actually, then, that's it.
If you follow these principles,
you should have
a well-working
task configuration.
I think I touched a cable here.
All right, we're back,
and, yeah, that's it.
Thank you very much.
So I'm now gonna
let the stage to David
for more exciting stuff.
Thanks very much.
[applause]
Tattersall: Okay, I'm gonna
stand well, well back
from that cable.
So that was all about
how to build stuff,
and now I'm gonna
show you some stuff
that's actually already
been built, and in a few cases,
actually already
running in the wild
and available
to people's users today.
So obviously, we had
several teams using the API
over the past few months,
and I would now like to invite
up to the stage
Roger, who is the founder
and Vice President of Products
and Platform at Mavenlink,
Naveen, who is
a tech lead at Zoho,
and Ilan, who is the founder
and C.E.O. of Producteev.
Guys.
[applause]
Neel: Thank you very much.
Nicolas, thanks for the
land mine here on the keyboard.
[laughter]
Neel: Um, so let me switch
over to Mavenlink.
So hi, I'm Roger.
I'm from Mavenlink.
We were invited
by the Google guys
to participate in
the Trusted Testers Program
for the Tasks API,
and I just want to express
my appreciation to them,
and also thank my team,
who's maybe watching
on YouTube right now,
for all the hard work getting
this feature delivered.
It's actually live
in production right now
based on the release,
and we're really excited,
and we've already gotten some
great customer feedback on it.
So a little bit of background--
Mavenlink is
an end-to-end application
to do work with clients,
so you'll see that I'm gonna
present a project workspace
where we're doing
some--some work
on a redesign for a web site
for one of our clients,
Sean Crafts, and one of
his colleagues, Jeff Moore.
Um, so, uh, we've been
in the Google Apps Marketplace
for about a year.
We were actually doing
the implementation
of some of
the other integrations,
uh, exactly a year ago today,
while many of you
were at Google I/O,
and now we're here,
less than one year later,
uh, expanding
on some of that stuff,
so just to give you
a little bit of background,
our original integration
with all the stuff
that you see on the right-hand
side of the screen,
where we have our tasks,
deliverables, and milestones,
we're actually syncing those
to your Google Calendar,
so now, with the release
of the Google Tasks API,
we were able to actually
synchronize the tasks,
which is kind of the main,
um, system of record
of what people are doing with
their clients in our system.
We're able to sync that
with your task list,
so that's what I'm gonna
show you now.
So this has been a big request
for our customer.
You can see here,
I'm in a project workspace.
Just to kind of give you
a little perspective
on what these guys were saying,
uh, you know, you have tasks
and task lists.
We create a task list
for each project,
so you have one or more projects
with a client,
and so we have our web site
redesign for ACME task list
and then a bunch of subtasks
that may or may not
be assigned to me.
If they're not assigned to me,
they don't come
in my Google Task list.
If they are assigned
to me, they do.
So we're kind of jumping into
the middle of a scenario here.
We've done a scoping session
with a client,
and now they're looking for us
to upload
our revision 1 mock-ups,
so I can fly that out,
complete this task,
which will complete it
in Mavenlink,
and then I can go to
my Google Calendar
or my Google e-mail,
and when I refresh
the task list here...
Neel: You can see that
the revision 1 mock-ups task
is now completed,
and it's completed over here.
We've done
a bidirectional sync.
We didn't implement
some of the polling
that Nicolas was mentioning,
but that's something
that's gonna be
a future feature for us,
but in this case,
we can complete more tasks
if we did, maybe,
a review with our client
and then come back to Mavenlink
and synchronize that.
So we have a little sync button
which kicks off a real-time poll
from Google
and then in our workspace,
uh, that AJAX is in
any completions,
and you can see
that we actually had
a few things to bulk sync here.
This got completed, and then
we have a couple new tasks
that were in
our Google Task list
that maybe I created before,
and so those get
synced up, as well.
So that's kind of the demo.
Um, you know, we'll--
I think we're coming up
to the stage to ask--
or answer any questions about
some of the best practices,
but, you know, we're really
excited about this.
We think that Tasks is really
the core of an e-mail workflow,
and Google is essentially
enabling apps like mine
to fit into that--
that third-party workflow.
So it's live now, like I said,
and actually, for Google I/O,
we're offering
50% off Mavenlink for life.
So if you'd like to come in,
sign up, give it a try,
try out our APIs,
you can do that.
Go to /googleio or ping me,
and I can set you up, as well.
[applause]
Venkat: Thanks, Roger.
Hello, everyone. I'm Naveen.
I work for Zoho,
where I head the team
responsible for
integrating Zoho
with Google Apps Marketplace
and other OpenSocial apps.
For those of you who are
not familiar with Zoho,
we offer
around 25 online services
ranging from the basic
productivity suite
all the way up
to CRM project management
invoicing, custom app building
platform, and much more.
Venkat: We have integrated
most of our business apps
with Google Apps Marketplace.
Over the last one year,
we have been consistently
adding new services
to Google Apps Marketplace
and have been constantly
enhancing features
to our existing services.
Zoho has thus grown to become
the largest vendor
in Google Apps Marketplace.
So coming to
Google Task integration,
when you think
about task management,
ideally, there should be
a single place
where you can manage your tasks,
but in reality,
that is not the case.
You may manage your personal
tasks in one application,
and if you're working
on a few projects,
you may maintain your tasks
in a project management,
and if you're a sales guy,
you'll end up maintaining
your tasks in a CRM application.
But what if you can manage
all your tasks
in one single place?
What if you can manage your
project and CRM-related tasks
in one application?
So this is basically what we
have done with theGoogle Tasks.
We have integrated tasks
from Zoho CRM and Projects
with Google Apps--Google Tasks.
So, um, I will start
with Zoho CRM.
Before that, uh, this
integration will go live soon,
but for now, let me show you
the screenshots
of, uh, how
this integration looks.
So in Zoho CRM,
users will be presented
with the configuration bar,
where they can specify
the Google Task list
to which the Zoho CRM task
can be pushed to.
Once this setup is in place,
the tasks that are added
in Zoho CRM
can be pushed to Google Tasks.
Also, when the user
edits a task in Zoho CRM,
the changes will be updated
in Google Tasks, as well.
Moving on,
here's how we have
integrated Google Tasks
with our project management app.
Users' tasks in Zoho Projects
can be exported,
along with their task list,
to Google Tasks.
Also, if there are any changes
made in Zoho Projects,
they will be automatically
updated in Google Tasks.
To sync the modifications
in Google Tasks,
we run a scheduler
for every 12 hours,
and if there are any changes,
it will be updated automatically
in the corresponding task.
So I hope you find
this integration useful.
We do have plans of extending
this integration
to the rest of the services.
I would like to thank Nicolas
for inviting me
to showcase our integration,
and also the Google team
for their wonderful support
right through the integration.
Thanks, guys.
[applause]
Abehassera: Hi, everyone.
I'm Ilan Abehassera,
and I'm the founder
and C.E.O. of Producteev.
Um, for those of you
who are not aware
of what Producteev is doing,
we're basically building
a task management platform
that lets you
collect your to-dos
from a lot
of different locations,
platforms, services, apps.
We're available
in a lot of Google services,
integration with Google apps,
um, Google Talk,
the Chrome Web app store,
Chrome extension,
and so on and so forth,
and we're here today to present
the Google Tasks integration.
All right, so I'm gonna do
a live demo.
Uh, we never know
if it's gonna work or not,
but we tried it
a couple of times
and it should be working fine.
Um, this is the Producteev
Web app here,
so as you can see,
this is my Google I/O project.
I have two tasks on it.
The first time I'm gonna do--
the first thing I'm gonna do
is connect my GMAIL account
with Producteev.
All right, so I'm doing
the whole process
so you can see
how seamless it is
to integrate both,
uh, products together.
Now I'm going back
to my workspace,
and now we're gonna see
my Google Tasks widget,
and as you can see,
those two tasks are already
available in my task list.
We also retrieve notes
and deadlines.
We synchronize both ways,
so let me show you
how that works from GMAIL
and Google Tasks to Producteev.
So let me turn this e-mail
into a task here,
so it's already available
in my Google Task--Task list,
and now I'm going back
to Producteev, refreshing,
and it's right there, as well.
Now just creating a new task,
uh, let's say "new brochure"
for next week.
We also understand
natural language processing,
so it's creating a new task
in Producteev.
It was deadlined for next week.
Going back to Google Tasks,
refreshing,
another time.
It takes, usually,
five to ten seconds.
Abehassera: It's gonna show up,
um, I promise.
And so basically,
just to sum it up,
what we do is
retrieving your tasks,
synchronize them both ways,
getting your,
um, deadlines and notes
on both services.
Let's try, and then I'm moving
on to my last slide.
There you go. Yeah.
[laughs]
[applause]
Abehassera: All right.
So, um, quickly,
about the technical
implementation itself--
we really loved
the documentation.
As you saw earlier,
everything is very detailed.
uh, lots of support
from the Google Tasks team,
well-structured API,
and also one of the--
lots of requests
that we got for Producteev
was the possibility
to turn any GMAIL e-mails
into a task on Producteev,
and now it's doable,
like I just showed you
in last, uh, last minute.
Thank you very much,
and thank you again
for the Google Tasks API.
[applause]
Tattersall: Thank you
very much, Ilan.
So that's the end
of our talk now.
Please, please do follow us
on Twitter, @googletasks.
If you are tweeting,
the hashtags are here,
and please also leave
some feedback, as well.
That short link leads you
to the SpeakerMeter page.
If you want to get
started straightaway,
the URI is up there,
and also I'd like to say,
just before we take questions,
it's taken a great many people
to get this API out the door,
and I'd like to say a huge, huge
thank-you to everyone involved.
I'm not gonna try
and list everyone
for fear of missing someone,
but you guys know who you are.
I particularly want to say
thank you so much
to the team back in Zurich,
and also to Andreas,
our tireless tech lead,
for keeping things running,
for Nicolas, for running
a great Developer Relations
Program, and for Fabian,
who literally sweat blood
and tears coding this API
from scratch for you guys.
Thank you very much.
[applause]
Tattersall: Also,
I thank you very much
for choosing this session,
and have a great journey
back from I/O,
and we'd love
to take any questions,
if I can invite the team up.
Coming up.
So we have
the first question mic.
man: Hi, so, um, the move method
you implemented--
is it strictly a helper?
I mean, obviously,
it's gonna enumerate
the different positions
and find the right value
to insert and so forth.
Does it have carnal knowledge
that we would be unable
to reproduce, or is it just
saving us the two-phase commit
of doing back and forth,
and so forth?
Schlup: Oh.
Uh, so I'm not sure I under--
so, you said--
what--what's your question?
man: So you implemented
a move API.
Schlup: Right.
man: But you exposed
the attributes of the elements
so that I could do a GET
and a PUT, and in theory, put it
back, but I have to have--
you know, I'm updating the
position values and so forth.
So is there something
about the move API
that does things that
we could not that guarantee it
to be better, more reliable,
or consistent?
I mean, 'cause the values
you put in there
are being generated
by the move API now.
It's inserting new values
for those position values.
So is there a convention?
Is there a pad?
If some app is doing
its own thing, it moves itself
its own way with its own set
of position values,
is something else gonna
get screwed up by that?
Like, was this purely a helper,
or is it that you have
specific knowledge about
how things are supposed to be?
Do you see my question or not?
Schlup: It--it's not
purely a helper
in that you cannot achieve
a move in any other way.
man: You can't?
If I do a--if I do a PUT
with the version number
and the new position number
and the predecessor,
why is that not the same thing?
Schlup: So we--a task doesn't
have a field
that defines its predecessor,
but it only has
this position field...
man: Ahh, the predecessor
is the same. Okay.
Schlup: Which we update for you
when you do the move.
man: But the position thing
determines the predecessor.
If I look at the previous
set of values,
I know the one, I can put
the thing in there.
Schlup: I don't hear it...
Tattersall: So the--I think--
you can't simply update
the position field because
they're not simply sequential.
They're kind of
automatically generated from
behind the scenes, and so if
you end up with loads of tasks,
at some point, you're gonna have
to do some sort of rebalancing.
man: So what you're saying
is we really should
absolutely not try to set
the position value anytime.
Schlup: No, that's correct.
The position values
are provided for you.
man: And we can't--
although we can set them
in the API, we should not.
Schlup: You cannot set them
in the API.
man: Oh, so they just come back
for informational purposes,
but--okay.
Schlup: Yes. Exactly, yes.
man: That's the question I had.
All right, thanks.
Schlup: Yeah.
Sorry about that.
man: Uh, just
a best practices question.
Uh, I have a task app
that has multiple
broken-down fields
and more specific data values,
like quantity and location,
things like that.
What's the best practices for
syncing that with Google Tasks,
which only has the title
and the notes
and due date field?
Is there a best practices
for how to itemize that
in the notes field,
or what to eliminate?
Signer: Yeah, so currently,
we don't support custom fields.
Um, there's basically
no best practice yet.
If you can easily somehow
serialize it into notes,
and it will show up
in Google Tasks,
and individuals
in GMAIL and Calendar,
so you can choose
sort of a half
machine-readable form
which still makes sense
to real users,
then that's cool,
but we don't have any better
advice than that at the moment.
man: Okay.
woman: Hi, I missed
the early part of your talk,
so if you covered it, I'm sorry.
Tattersall: [chuckles]
woman: Um, it's actually
a two-part question.
One was that it's usually
a very popular use case
to be able to do
coordinated tasks,
so if I have four people
in my family,
can I have one PUT that goes
into all four accounts,
and kind of like know
who's finishing it?
Is the Tasks API gonna
support that down the line,
in the sense of maybe
having a PUT to a group
rather than a person?
And the other part
of the question was,
um, I think I saw something
which allows me
to basically do a GET
from different applications
for my--for my
task queue, right?
So do you automatically
do notifications
if one of the apps
deletes a task?
Do you notify other apps
that are looking at it,
things like that?
Tattersall: So I can answer
the question about social tasks.
So if you read our blog post,
which was the beginning of
January, it basically summed up
the results from the user survey
we did in December,
and one of the largest feature
requests was for social tasks,
so things like assigning tasks,
sharing tasks, sharing lists.
So this is some feedback
we've obviously taken on board.
I'm not putting a lot of energy
into the Tasks part his year,
so I can't comment
on road maps specifically,
but we definitely know
it's a really common use case.
woman: Okay, so kind of
to build on that, I'm assuming
there's no other attribute
that just says whether this is
a public or a private task,
like at the very low level.
There's no other attribute,
other than string,
that defines the task, right?
Tattersall: Sorry, I didn't
hear the question.
woman: Oh, sorry. I was saying,
right now, on the Tasks,
you don't have any attribute
that sets it to a public
or private. It's just an app--
Tattersall: Yeah, right now,
the only person who can access
the set of lists is yourself.
woman: Is the person. Okay.
Tattersall: Only private to you.
woman: All right, thanks.
man: I noticed
in all of your examples,
the PUTs have all
of the attributes of the task,
but some of them are immutable,
so are they--can you--
is there any, um, need
to specify those?
Schlup: No, there's--no.
man: Okay, so you--
Schlup: There's no need
to specify them.
man: Partial updates are fine.
Schlup: Yeah.
man: And I'm just curious
why--did you make
a conscious decision
not to include client data,
like maybe one private field
or one custom field?
Or, why did you choose to leave
out custom fields altogether?
Tattersall: There was the
question, are we gonna include
custom fields at some point?
man: Yes, I guess that's it.
Tattersall: It's a Labs API, so
we're gonna want to treat it
on your feedback, so we know
it's a use case, basically.
Schlup: We just tried
to focus, with version 1,
to get out there what we have
available in GMAIL today
and go--take it from there.
man: It wasn't really
a criticism.
I just--I was interested
in the thought process
as much as, um, as much
as anything else. Thanks.
Tattersall: Hey.
man: Hi, um, I-I was wondering
if, uh, the task
has an associated e-mail,
like when you select
the "More Actions" button,
an associated task
with an e-mail,
is that, that way now
in the API?
Tattersall: So the--when you
create a task from the e-mail,
can you get the e-mail thing?
man: Yeah.
Tattersall: So, yeah, it's not
included in the API right now,
but we're gonna be
bringing it out soon.
man: Okay, and the other
question is,
Since this task API
supports OAuth,
um, is, uh, can we ask
Google Apps administrator
access, uh, like,
all domains users task
by--on behalf of them?
Garnier: Uh, yeah, so we--
the API do support
two-legged OAuth,
so, yes, the administrator can--
I mean, if he's
an administrator for,
um, apps for
your business domain,
yeah, he can access, you know,
using the two-legged
OAuth mechanism,
all the tasks from all his,
you know, users.
man: Thank you.
Garnier: Yep, thank you.
Tattersall: Are there
any more questions?
Garnier: Yeah, I think
that's it. Last chance.
We're gonna... [laughs]
We're gonna wrap it up.
Tattersall: Did anyone get
an implementation running
during the session,
or was I too, uh--
Garnier: It's cool. We had
no hard questions. Thanks.
Tattersall: Well, thank you
very much for coming, guys.
Garnier: [speaking indistinctly]
No. [laughs]
Tattersall: Yeah, thank you
very much for coming,
uh, and have
a great journey home.
I hope you enjoyed I/O, and
enjoy your new tablets, as well.
They're coming, yes.
Garnier: Thank you very much.